and at the table is Pat showed who you
may recognizes having run for vice
president back in 96 with ross perot
this book just came out this week it's
called dangerous business the risks of
globalization for America mr. chota
remind us the definition of
globalization what exactly does it mean
the way that I use it is the way that
the US isn't whining its economy with
those of other nations and my argument
is is that we have done it without
thought without building in safeguards
we've thrown open air markets in such a
way without safeguards that it threatens
our sovereignty our prosperity our
national security my personal security
with the number of poison foods poison
toys poisoned defective goods that we
allow into this country without
inspection you dig back to the 90s and
some key moments and key legislative
items that we saw here one of them was
NAFTA the other was the start of the WTO
World Trade Organization speak to those
two moments in the 90s and what they had
meant for our conditions today well
basically what happened with at the end
of the Cold War Europe Japan and the
United States had the great geopolitical
question of how do you bring into the
global economy four billion people who
were not in that economy were basically
in controlled by socialist or communist
governments the route that we chose was
unfettered globalization and unfettered
opening of our markets and at the same
time to give our firms assurances that
if they invested overseas if foreign
governments were to take over those
investments that they'd be made a hole
in it we set up a trap a great trend for
the working people of the United States
and the [ __ ] was if companies stayed in
the United States and obeyed our laws
obeyed our labor laws our safety laws
are environmental laws they would go
broke or if they would go to Mexico or
if they'd go to China or the
to other countries they could have penny
wage labor they would have no regulation
on the environment and worker safety and
they can make a great deal of money and
that's precisely what happened that's
what in the NAFTA debate and the WTO
debate we were arguing we were the
opponent's we're saying this is going to
destroy a major part of our economy our
sovereignty our security and what I do
in this book is I document what has
happened how that happens and but I
spent about a third of this book talking
about how America can make it come back
if we are just simply willing to accept
that America a role in the world that
our prosperity our economy is lost then
it'll be lost on the other hand there
aren't things that we can do to bring
America back and that's what I lay out
in this book and I detail it and some
specificity will get you to speak trivum
of those details Jenna moment want to
enlight the viewers to phone him with
their questions and comments Republicans
line on the top 20 27 37 triple zero one
Democrats at seven three seven zero zero
zero two and four independent 20 to 60
to 80 205 our guest is Pat Choate author
of dangerous business the risks of
globalization for America mr. choate was
ross perot's vice presidential candidate
running mate in 1996 well turn to those
solutions how can America in your words
make it come back give us a couple of
examples well the first thing that we've
got to do is change the people then Stan
fire governments I have in the bank of
this book a list of 500 Republicans and
Democrats that held a public office from
1993 Ford this is the Clinton and the
Bush administration's that then became a
registered lobbyist or foreign agents
they went to work for special interests
that one of the key recommendations in
this book is that the next president
require a federal ethics contract with
every one of his 6,000 employees savory
that for five years after they leave
office they won't lobby the role agency
that they
won't become a foreign agent that if
they're in the trade business they will
not assist foreign governments or
transnational corporations get around
the trade deals that they do the other
thing that air urge is that all cabinet
officers do a financial filing for five
years after they leave office just as
senators do now and that ex-presidents
do it for life this is I think leads to
questionable ethics people who come into
office and and use their tenure
seemingly to develop a lobbying client
list we need to stop that we can't make
the hard decisions unless people are
clearly working for the best interest of
the American people how about some more
examples second dynamic fine secondly
the doha a trade round has failed it is
collapsed after seven years the next
president and the next Congress have a
clean slate owned renegotiating these
trade deals we should move in very
aggressively and say to the hundred and
fifty two other 151 other members of the
world trade organization that the next
trade negotiations must first of all
have proportionate voting at the WTO
right now it's one country one boat so
our boat has the same weight as the
island country of Antigua if we have
twenty-two percent of the global economy
we should have 22 / some of the votes
second is that there be great
transparency it's now a very secretive
organization trials are held in closed
session the materials and those trials
are kept closed the results of those
drones that rationale are kept closed I
mean I actually proposed in the book
that c-span establish an office at the
WTO it would be a wonderful thing for
America to see the organization that
rules on our trade laws that rules on
our domestic laws how those decisions
are made and then the third thing I say
about the WTO there's a great
discrimination against American products
in the world by the way that it's taxed
under the provisions of the world trade
agreement and indirect tax can be
rebated so if Mercedes Benz produces in
Germany a car
and sends it to the United States the
mercedes-benz company gets a nineteen
percent tax rebate of at rebate from the
German government if general motor sends
a Cadillac to Germany General Motors
gets no credit for the corporate taxes
that they pay here plus they must pay
nineteen percent and on of event
equivalent inside Germany this
disadvantages American companies in the
world by about three hundred and fifty
eight billion dollars a year we should
simply say it to the other countries
that this must be ended and there are
several ways that I prescribe to do it
that is within the context of what is
legal and within the bounds of our
treaty obligations it's those kinds of
things that we can do that we're within
the bounds of the agreements that we
have and within the bounds of our own
law that will make a radical difference
in helping this country come back well
let's get to those calls for patch out
first one is a Pleasant Hill California
hi there hi again hello cyanide to speak
fun on our yeah yes go ahead with your
question yeah I was wondering what the
United States government and all its
lobbyists are doing about the resurgence
of death squads El Salvador i I don't
know that's not within my expertise and
it's not covered in this book let's try
thing I tell Texas good morning to you
good morning thank you good morning mr.
Cho good morning my question is I would
like to know if mr. Cho could talk a
little bit about this rush to enter into
public private partnerships with foreign
companies and the flood of foreign money
in our infrastructure development and
how that's going to impact us in the
long run I cover that in fact in this
book and I talked about the Illinois
Turnpike being sold by the state
government of Indiana I talked about the
Texas of private public partnerships one
of the three major agendas of the Bush
administration in the second term was
first private
Social Security was second to shift a
major part of the work done by the
federal government to private companies
and the third was to shift the
interstate financing and the
construction of new roads to toll roads
now this is a very controversial move
its controversial because the American
people in many cases have paid for these
roads and what governors are doing and
happened in Indiana is they sold a lease
on the Indiana Turnpike 157 mile road
built in the early 50s for something
like 3.8 billion dollars a private
company from Australia will operate that
road for a period of 75 years that
company will raise the toes and in fact
the tolls there have been doubled and
then doubled again and that the company
will control a swath of land through the
middle of Indiana ten miles on each side
of the road there's a no-compete claw so
if the state or the cities do anything
that divert traffic from the toll road
then they must pay this private
concessionaire there were Senate
hearings three weeks ago the senator
jeff Bingaman held and it was revealed
in those hearings that if that had been
done by a private authority rather than
if it had been done by a public
authority rather than a private
concessionaire that could have been done
for thirty percent less and there's an
example in dallas texas where a private
company had bid the contract and then a
public authority took the contract and
the public is already did the same work
for thirty percent less madison
mississippi you're up now yes sir good
morning good morning mr. fudge I was a
extra question what do you think about
oh I did I found your book very
surprising and very deep because
globalization does affect Americans also
i was looking at what saudi arabia the
prayers pumping $20 20 billion dollars
into citibank and
you have other factories and other banks
being bought by Saudi Arabia also China
dumping our dollars in Russia dumping
our dollars i think that was on the news
just recently what do you think about
Russia dumping american dollars and what
implication of a globalization have to
put european see an American also in
Europe into economic slavery well
there's a very good website it's called
economy in crisis dot org this site
identifies every American company that's
been bought by a foreign entity or a
foreign government since 1978 it
identified 16,000 companies since the
beginning of this year there have been
1,200 American companies sold to foreign
entities one of the things I do in this
book I get into a discussion of
something called sovereign wealth firms
and the sovereign wealth funds in these
funds what you find in Saudi Arabia and
other countries Norway take state funds
and they use that to buy private
enterprises the largest such fund in the
world is going to be out of China China
has about three trillion dollars of
public money that they're now beginning
to use to buy private companies to buy
minerals to buy assets around the world
let me put this into context China can
take a trillion dollars to defend its
currency can then take two trillion
dollars and they can today by
twenty-five percent of the companies
listed on the new york stock control
absolute control twenty-five percent
other companies listed on the new york
stock exchange one of the great
challenges the next president the next
Congress is going to face is whether or
not they're going to permit a communist
government that's in direct competition
with the united states both economically
and strategically to buy our means of
production when you look at the two
candidates from the major Party Senator
McCain senator Obama what are you
hearing that too like from either
candidate what are you concerned about
that you're hearing well let me stir
with my concern my concern is both
candidates are using his advisors the
people that brought us globalization
that is a deep concern and I see nothing
to suggest that those advisors have
learned anything or forgotten anything
about those experiences what is why I'm
hopeful is the American people i think
are ready to change economic policies
something like seventy seven percent of
the american voters say they're
dissatisfied with the economic policies
of george bush which are the policies of
globalization so much has happened in
1933 when franklin roosevelt became and
running against the economics of herbert
hoover both presidents will have the
option to run against the policies of
george bush and the policies of
globalization the second big thing and I
just can't emphasize this enough the
failure of the Doha around gives the
next president and the next Congress an
opportunity a clean slate to go back and
renegotiate these deals it is very clear
after seven years of failed negotiations
that there is not global agreement on
what globalization should be and this is
not unique incidentally in American
history when we created the United
States and was first governed by the
Articles of Confederation which we found
out didn't work right and we had to go
back about ten years later and do the
Constitution of the United States the
WTO as it's now structured is structured
in such a way that's against the
interest of the American people and in
fact against the interest of most
working people it's set into the
interest of transnational corporations
and finance ears now is the moment for
us to go back and do it so I'm I can be
hopeful and do we run our presidential
candidates our candidates have to do it
as though they're playing poker hide
their cards and what they're doing so we
can't know we really don't know at this
point all we can say is there's going to
be a great opportunity for the next
president
be great so you don't have a sense of
which of those two candidates would be
in the best position to move a
Democratic Congress in the direction you
want them to move well a Democratic
president would have the best
opportunity to move a Democratic
president in that direction but a
Democratic president has to be willing
to focus on jobs in the economy and talk
about the kinds of things I'm talking
about if a Republican president would
would do these kinds of things I think
they'd find a very receptive Democratic
Congress austin texas for Pat choked
welcome to the program good morning
morning there first of all I want to say
this I really want to let you down the
feast and commentaries law you do an
outstanding job of staying neutral in
your commentary and I really
appreciations going to create that
gentleman of the gentleman on there not
European statement brought tears to my
eyes abdomen constructions and john and
charles finish coffee for the past 23
years and everything you said is exactly
as I feel terrible for his church is
back in 02 for the housing of the
soldiers we will not allow to use any
iron that didn't come from China that I
am of inspecting all the pole we needed
inspected for stickers from China and
wonderful China you are not allowed to
you Velma leaving from Chicago and this
destroyed the whole city of Chicago and
they stopped using on and destroyed that
I'm in love again if you in Chicago I
just want to say I wish everybody
admission to let your phone because all
the job in this country are gone from
college degrees all about the outdoors
of your cell phone coming all for
helping successful but also love and
care how to understand the people on the
phone but I would appreciate that you
don't respawn keep up to go thanks let's
Choate anything to say there well if
anyone wants to see the numbers on this
I have some in the back another great
place to go is ross perot's new website
remember the charts he used in his
campaigns sure didn't he's updated them
all he just put them up on the web it's
called Perot charts calm all the charts
of their updated
to the summer how often do you talk to
mr. Perrelli days Oh once a month once
every six weeks what kind of angry what
kind of things do you talk about how is
he doing well basically sometimes we
talk about politics sometimes about a
book sometimes about his website barry's
angels what friends would talk about
what was it like running for vice
president what was a 12 12 years ago it
was wonderful i enjoyed it do speaking
having an opportunity to go out and talk
to the American people is a wonderful
experience you feel better after the
experience and we running with Ross was
great less than a Laurel Maryland good
morning to you good morning hello good
more than watching c-span since it
started and I just wanted to go back to
what he said about lobbyists and c-span
did a whole thing about 1996 about the k
street lobbyists and that's the problem
nothing gets done they go in to get
elected for a few years then they turn
around they become lobbyists and that's
just it gums up the whole system and
they get their way and it's got to stop
well in the back of my book I run an
appendix of former members of Congress
who've become lobbyists half of the
members of Congress who have left office
since 1998 are now working as lobbyists
becoming a lobbyist is the branch ring
of public service today and we've got to
stop it if we're going to bring America
back do the changes in a lobbyist rules
passed by Congress mean anything to you
not really no no they really don't do it
I mean the very idea that a constituent
cannot buy a member of Congress a
sandwich or a breakfast and that is
considered reform is absurd on the face
of it Trenton Michigan you are on the
air go ahead Trenton good morning mr.
Churchill and mr. for Joe this is my
first time calling and after getting a
different franchise with the other major
media network that are the watching
c-span about six months ago and you guys
are the tops
no slant and wonderful on that but my
question was is that I've been always
fascinated with a the North American
Free Trade Agreement more so during the
Clinton years and left so during the
Bush to Bush junior years but um I'm
always hearing Bill Clinton get the
credit for the NAFTA agreement when I
believe it was Bush Senior that did the
bulk of the work who did one where the
president george herbert walker bush
Nageotte negotiated the NAFTA agreement
he signed it in december of 1992 the
clinton administration then hired carlet
hills who had been the US Trade
Representative to assist him over the
next year to bring the thing through so
the deal was negotiated by President
Bush it was completed by President
Clinton which I think underscores a
point that I make in this book is that
what we have come is to one-party rule
essentially we have a situation for
example a master two-thirds of the
American people to post NAFTA and it
passed overwhelmingly in both houses of
the US Congress it's obviously done this
economy a great harm there's been no
real movement in the Congress to
renegotiate the deal what we have and I
make a third of my book is how did we
come to this situation and I conclude
its mercantilism in global trade not
free trade but mercantilism export trade
secondly corporatism corporate entities
financial institutions really taking
over the financing of our politics and
third elitism a large group of people
whose interests are divorcing those of
the nation and the American people you
put that combination together you wind
up with both Republicans and Democrats
supporting this unfettered globalization
but
I think we're running to the end of that
we're seeing the consequences with the
damaged goods and the poison foods and
the defective medicines that are coming
in the American people understand that's
bad for them we see it with the loss of
jobs we see it with a lowered income for
most of Americans we see it and this
great divide in ownership inside the
country the sharing of wealth where a
tiny portion of one percent has as much
as the rest of the population the
question is what do we do about it or do
we do something about it I think that's
going to be the great challenge for the
next president and i think the things
that we're talking about this morning
are the things that will eventually make
a difference we have about 15 minutes
left or so with our gasp at Choate and
Chicago you are waiting on the line go
ahead please hello Chicago and I have a
quite a lot go ahead i didn't have my
button pushed up but now i do we can
hear you fine go ahead alone okay good
morning first ever commented then I have
a question and the first comment if I
want to really thank you sir for
educating the American public because a
lot of this we really don't know and you
don't great service cuz you know things
that I have some issues with you guys
but you always come through I'm bringing
people like him you know you always
cleaned up whatever conflict i had with
you and I really appreciate this man was
it my question to you sir is how do the
g8 summit right into the globalization
issue i mean how did these global
economic summits time basically what you
have is the leaders of the country have
been agreeing to try to get an agreement
on the new global trade agreement they
keep pushing this and yet what they find
when they go back home is that their
people don't want it in this last
agreement it was the Chinese and Indians
that destroyed the agreement because
when it got down to the final moments
the Chinese Indians like the way the
things were now I think America is lucky
that they did that
it gives us at our next president the
opportunity to go redo it and redo it
correctly Melbourne Florida good morning
good morning yes sir I agree with a lot
of what you're saying but can you match
this up with the realization of
resources in this country where you
cannot access American resources and
these companies have moved to where the
resources are able to to get them if you
try to even build a building in my
County the growth they want to stop
growth everywhere in my County you
cannot build manufacturing jobs in this
country match this up with labor and
resources because the labor force will
go for two years collecting unemployment
before getting a job that they could get
they'd rather wait and get a job that
they are going to get paid more than
their last job the two that the average
American changes jobs every two years
and this will not work with
manufacturing the country has to come to
a realization that we need to access our
resources here and if you brought back
all the jobs right now who would work
them because we're already employing
illegal aliens through the whole country
and the job rate has been at a
historical well right now our population
growth Wilma will not provide full mouth
provide for these manufacturing jobs
that you you want to bring back let's
hear from our guest first thank you for
the question I disagree with you on your
premise we have large numbers of people
inside the United States with skills
that would be delighted to do these
manufacturing jobs for several years I
was involved in the southern United
States and had bleach or Tennessee
Oklahoma Georgia working on economic
development you go through those regions
and you will find hundreds if not
thousands of Bandung abandoned
manufacturing sites i was invited by Leo
Gerard of the steelworkers a couple of
weeks to go to go to Chicago and talk to
the policy committee of the answer bail
see
I oh I can tell you absolutely that's 50
plus presidents there you have people
there that are fully committed and bring
back manufacturing and the confined and
train the workers America can come back
and we must have a strong manufacturing
base what we need is policies that will
enable app this is all a function of
what kind of economic policies trade
policies we put into place in
globalization we put in trade policies
and economic policies that encourage
companies to leave we need to reversal
that and have policies that will
encourage companies to invest in the
United States and create good-paying
jobs with good benefits what would you
have to say about these pocket but
pocketbook issues that are so much talk
about right now gas prices food prices
even bigger issues like housing market
what's your perspective well on the on
the housing market and part of that this
is an absolute failure of the financial
system this is a direct consequence of
deregulating getting rid of the
glass-steagall Act Wall Street has
become the they've become clip toe
maniacs taking advantage of a situation
and they've turned out to be incompetent
bankers they've launched over 500
billion dollars of their own assets of
most of those banks were treated as you
or I or small business they'd be in
chapter 7 liquidation so we need rear
egg ulation of that so that's the first
thing is to the question of food it has
been a big mistake in our policy to say
that we want to import our food from
world markets we need to be able at a
minimum in this country to produce all
the food that we need we need as a
country to be willing to stand forth and
say that we will solve world hunger that
we will send food to other countries
we've gone just the opposite way with
this whole question of globalization in
to what extent do energy prices plan to
the things that you're talking about
thinking about these well as they play a
major role I mean but basically my view
on the question of energy is that we
have cartels that work
and one of the first things that we need
to do is enforce an antitrust policy
that says the oil companies can own the
coal companies they can own the wind
companies they can't and on the new
technology that's the first thing you
aren't competition among forms of energy
the second thing that we need is to get
on with tax credits with new innovations
and we need to strengthen our patent
policies inside this country I mean
devising these new energy sources is
going to create an economic boom much
like with some of the 80s and 90s and
creating a computer industry if we will
have strong patent policies that will
allow investors to make sure they know
that they will not have their patents
stolen or their technologies pirated
then we'll have massive investment and
we'll solve this problem next call
emporia kansas thank you for waiting
you're on with Pat choked yes thank you
I've a comment and a question people
should not forget that the Clintons were
responsible for NAFTA which was a time
bomb for American jobs you mentioned how
far in countries like Saudi Arabian
Norway and even China could buy American
companies and that were allowing foreign
governments to buy our means of
production aren't we doing the same with
oil in Iraq last year and oil man ray
hunts made a deal to buy oil from the
Kurds in northern Iraq and that was
against the Iraqi government which is
supposed to represent all the Iraqi
people well I mean again this is elitism
that incorporate ISM that spread around
the goal globe at my point about all of
this is it is up to us the American
people and our government to protect
ourselves against such greed and such
rapacious practices New Orleans you are
on the air now morning yes good morning
and I I'm really enjoying your show mrs.
jokes I all whole heartily agree with
everything you said I work for the
federal government
and I believe also that contractors are
running our country and if they're
selling out to foreigners that's even
scarier i watch all the time home these
contractors write our RFP and stating
the worst and then they get the award
they're awarded the contract it's
amazing but excuse me my question is
what can the average American citizen do
all to change the course of this this
whole process because like you said
we're basically we're running ourselves
into the ground and we're so now I think
almost better than half of the country
already belongs to China what can we do
as an average American citizens to
change the course of all of this we're
about America talks about big things
whenever we have presidential elections
we're about two months away from this
election people should contact these
candidates for president the candidates
for Congress and the Senate and let them
know that the number one issue on your
mind is the economy and jobs and that
you want to bring back America you want
this country to have a self-sufficiency
to the extent that we can that you want
to create good jobs here and that you do
not want to sell America wanted you to
touch on this a little bit further patch
out its chapter eight you talk about
security did you write the US spends
more on national security than all the
other nations combined its approach to
globalization however massively
undermines the very security that money
supposedly buys tell us more in the
mid-1960s the Clinton administration
issued an order that instructs
contractors to find the lowest price
good anywhere they can and encourages
them and I cite the executive the
purchase instructions in the book that
encourages them to find foreign sources
at the same time what is happening is
the department of defense does not keep
accurate records of where the goods come
from
so we found ourselves in the Iraqi war
we didn't have the capacity to produce
all the bullets we need which is rather
fundamental for war we find on the
propellants that we're using on our
anti-tank weapons we're purchasing that
from China when we take a look at the
critical technologies lists that are
necessary for many of these exotic
weapons something like twenty percent of
those are coming from China and the
China sphere the assumption is that if
we have difficulties with China let's
say China were to invade Taiwan that
they would continue to ship us these
advanced technology products I mean this
is dangerous let's just put it that way
maybe dumb or stupid would be more
appropriate but it's certainly dangerous
we need to go back and take a look at
our defense industrial base and say what
do we need to make sure that we have an
assured capacity to defend ourselves
within our own borders last couple calls
for our guest Indianapolis good morning
hi I the reason why don't get involved
with politics of is because there's a
moral vacuum it seems like I'm in
Indianapolis Indiana and I'm represented
by Andre Carson I really don't feel like
I'm representative in a in a
representative form of government I
thought useless ever presented I don't
anybody reflecting my values but my
question is maybe it's too far out but
is there any altruistic motives for
giving money to let's say South America
for their goods and then us not tearing
their goods coming in is there a motive
for democracy you mentioned Germany I
just only 50 years ago or 75 years ago
whatever it was it had aa the Berlin
crisis are we supporting them with our
money all terrifically as Americans are
we actually doing good by by paying
those tariffs to them well basically
what we're doing is we're making
ourselves dependent we're running these
massive trade deficits
with other countries around the world
including China 256 billion this year we
can't continue this we're going broke as
a country when that stops what we're
going to find is those countries are not
going to have markets for their goods
we've got to wean ourselves away from a
dependency on barring foreign money to
finance our lifestyle and at the same
time we've got to begin the process of
weaning them away for being there being
dependent on us as the market that's why
I say the next president should use this
historic opportunity to go in and
rethink our trade policy and renegotiate
our trade agreements Kalamazoo you're on
the air good morning Pat that I've been
in the end in the industry for many many
years not retired and your comments
relative to the high-tech element of the
military industrial complex is really
valid it's even more basic than that
actually if you look at the bearing
industry among which a lot of this
machinery runs that industry is pretty
well gone now in the United States and
we're importing much of that basic
hardware to sustainer know our military
equipment as well as commercial
equipment I think also we should be
focusing primarily on rebuilding our
infrastructure in this country as
something that we can do specifically in
the area of high speed rail and other
means of conveyance even looking to
advanced forms of transportation
transportation other than even
high-speed rail that would be a great
stimulus that coupled with the pursuit
of other energy resources that are fully
within our control thank you speak to
the infrastructure issue well this
uh we need to rebuild our infrastructure
it's about a two trillion dollar job it
can be a major stimulus to rebuilding
our economy and creating millions of
jobs and moreover we do not need to sell
our infrastructure to the private sector
to Wall Street to do this there's more
than sufficient capital to do it through
private authorities are just more clever
uses of the monies that we have I talked
about that in some extent inside this
book but this is just another example
the energy the infrastructure the whole
process of bringing America back we just
need to convey to our president that
that's what we want them to do we don't
want them to conduct a national
liquidation sale we want them to help
bring America back touching back on that
energy issue mr. chota speaker Pelosi so
the house is going to rethink the
drilling issue use the resources that we
have here like that last caller right
right what does this mean to you it it
means that we're moving I think wisely
we need we need to drill right now
because we need it but we also need the
tax credit own energy R&D tax credit and
we need to start investing into new
forms of energy and we need to make sure
we keep our patent system strong so
investors will put money into new
technologies speak a little more broadly
about the immigration issue which was
brought up both legal and illegal what
what does the immigration have issued
mean to this whole idea of globalization
and the premise of your book dangerous
business well at its most basic level it
means that under NAFTA we've had
American and other companies exploiting
the people of Mexico one of the things
that Ross Perot and I did in our book
about NAFTA we warned that if we did
that deal the way that we did it is that
you would have massive amounts of
American corn going to Mexico and it
would knock out the peasant farmers and
Mexico and their only opportunity would
be to come to the United States it's
happened precisely that way so a long
term on the legal immigration issue is
we've got to do what's necessary to help
Mexico grow to help Mexico create jobs
much as Europe did with Spain in
Portugal in the 20th century we need to
not make the United States and magnet
the second thing that we need to do is
stop the exploitation of Mexican and
other workers that come into this
country even though they're in here
illegally we need heavily fine employers
that will not hire Americans and exploit
illegal immigrants and as I point out in
the interim we probably need to finish
and build that fence I went to Israel a
couple of months ago and took a look at
their fence and it works offense can
work and it's actually a humanitarian
thing if people know they can't get
across that border they're not going to
be out there in the desert dying by the
hundreds so but the longer term solution
here is to stop the exploitation of the
illegal immigrants in our labor markets
and secondly help Mexico grow and create
jobs they're an important neighbor we
should take a special responsibility to
help them bring their income levels
after our own call her now from my la
you want with a choked hello there good
morning Paul a good morning mr. choke
and where have you been writing a book
sir my goodness I sure hope c-span
re-airs this program i am a c-span
junkie and living on the west coast i
get up at four o'clock religiously doing
a lot of every morning you unlock and
c-span you are doing a wonderful job in
letting Americans expressed unbiased or
should I say unfiltered comments and
making their views known mr. choked I
just want to know
if there's any way to get in touch with
you I know your book is out i will be
purchasing it thank you because i think
your ideas and your viewpoints are
expressions that are filled by Americans
far and wide and I just want to thank
you for your comment sir thank you you
can contact me through the publisher I'm
out on book tour and so they know where
i am and at all times last call
blairsville Georgians good morning yes
good morning Paul I don't want to mr.
shelf good morning ah yes I would like
that I agree with your honor percent on
what's wrong with the exploitation of
our middle class and our market our milk
white well our market has been sold to
globalization buy our politicians they
use protectionism which is I think a
good thing and and also isolationism but
they made a dirty word out of that and
also but my question to you sir is be
what we call the federal reserve bank
but jackpot which is really a global
bank you know and really doesn't look
out for the interest of the dollar or
the business going on in this country
and our middle class of wealth been so
you have any comments on really what the
Federal Reserve Bank is involved in this
how they connect with their totalization
they are heavily involved with the
globalization the bank has made some
major mistakes in this decade one of the
first was not seeing the mortgage
scandal when it was very clear that it
was happening they did not aggressively
move on that a friend of mine named Bill
grider who is rights also and economics
makes a very persuasive case at the time
has come to make the Federal Reserve a
bit more responsive to the American
people into our political system he
would bring and put it under the US
Treasury
and it operate as an independent agency
that's owned literally owned and
controlled by the bankers in the banking
system attached Otranto vice president
back in 1996 with ross perot he is
author of this new book dangerous
business the risks of globalization for
America thanks a lot for your time after
taking calls this morning it's great
being with appreciate value